bonjour francis carole bonjour bonjour
ce que nous font le plaisir douanes de
côté êtes le chef de file du palis masse
et le parti pour la libération de la
martinique également conseiller exécutif
en charge des affaires sociales nous y
reviendrons mais vous êtes depuis
quelques jours le désormais candidat à
la législative à fort de france avec
tout le soutient francis carole du
mouvement indépendantiste martiniquais
d'alfred marie jeanne
c'est tout sauf une surprise disons que
nous nous situons dans une continuité de
mon action de mon action politique qui
ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
je crois que le président marc jones et
c'est ce qui était pourtant il a précisé
lors de sa réunion des militants du
mouvement et il a précisé qu'il fallait
s'en tenir à l'essentiel et l'essentiel
aujourd'hui c'est d'amplifier la
victoire de du grand semblait et il a
considéré que j'étais celui qui pouvait
avoir avait mis des moteurs de votre don
il a toujours des débats - je me suis un
démocrate je considère que les débats
sont nécessaires soient utiles et dans
de ce point de vue ça ne me gêne pas
qu'il puisse y avoir des il a quand même
été question un moment au sein même du
mime qu'il y ait quatre candidats de ce
mouvement indépendantiste sur les quatre
circonscriptions actuellement et le
prise d'un malaise a considéré que cette
stratégie n'était pas bonne parce que
nous sommes dans ce bloc le
rassemblement firent gens nous sommes
dans un bloc mais il faut savoir aller à
l'essentiel
aujourd'hui l'enjeu pour nous ce n'est
pas d'aller compter nos voix
l'enjeu pour nous c'est de gagner pour
tenter de changer le pays et ça se pose
de manière très différents de manière
radicalement différente
il ya une manière de poser des choses
quand il s'agit simplement de la peau ma
promotion de tel ou tel parti
il ya une autre manière de concevoir les
choses quand on considère l'intérêt
général alors francis carole sur la
circonscription de fort de france avec
qui comme suppliant pour s'orienter
ça fait partie des questions que nous
aurons à débattre de nom de marilyn
démarre bien oui c'est une c'est une des
possibilités mais nous allons débattre
de tout cela avec nous
nous avions alors je fais pipi leur lui
sera dans le sud voilà qui était
définitivement toutes les rumeurs de
toutes sortes qui le voyaient dans le
centre atlantique pour ce centre
atlantique puisque vous êtes dans la
même famille et des confidences à nous
faire il ya des noms qui sortent du
chapeau pour le non non je n'ai pas
particulièrement de la banlieue parce
que le moment venu je parce que ce sont
deux circonscriptions le nord et le
centre qui font l'objet de sept nouveaux
de discussion parce que l'analyse est un
peu plus complexe et à ce niveau là et
le moment venu les uns et les autres que
dix mois ce qu'ils ont décidé en tout
cas nous avons encore le temps
bah oui attendre à fort de france les
choses sont claires votre adversaire ce
sera serge letchimy bête blessée depuis
décembre dernier avec les élections et
s'était même pas morte du tout une
forteresse imprenable dans le fief même
du ppm
oui ça fait partie aussi des engagements
que j'ai pris
il ya très tour n'oubliez pas que qu'à
l'âge de 28 ans je conduisais une 18
états unis c'est en tout cas d
imposition pour essayer d'ébranler le
bastion de ppr parce que le fort de
france c'est le des endroits où une
force politique a pu constituer
véritablement un bastion ce bastion
était en train de s'effriter
vous l'avez constaté à deux queues et 7
bastion complètement ébréché on le voit
avec des résultats des élections
nous nous rappelons qu'au deuxième tour
des élections territoriales nous avons
fait plus de 13 mille voix jeudi nous
collectivement à quelque 2000 voix de
l'actuel président du néo ppm
c'est dire que les choses sont en train
de changer il y à des bouleversements
sociologiques et les conditions
générales qui s'opposaient ouvre la
possibilité de gagner ces élections les
stades est confirmée c'est pas assez
confiance et je ne veux pas sinon
adverse est une bête je ne sais pas s'il
est alors messieurs l'expression les
miens ce que ce que je veux simplement
dire c'est que nous devons nous
collectivement qui l'a mené de ce
qu'elle fait ce café alfred marie-jeanne
alfred marie-jeanne qu'on croyait
complètement mort en 2010 à des voiries
est revenue au devant de la scène mon
point de vue c'est de ne jamais méprisé
l'adversaire de n'a jamais considéré que
c'est
des choses sont faites des sons gagne il
faut se battre et la peine que je
voulais faire ce matin c'est un appel à
renforcer notre solidarité a enfoncé le
rassemblement et à se mettre
immédiatement au travail pour que les
victimes puissent être acquise alors
quelle sera la faille pour mettre à
terre le parti progressiste martiniquais
dans cette élection bien particulière
que représentent les législatives il
faut dire très simplement il faut tirer
un bilan qu'est ce que j'observe
simplement j'observe un certain nombre
de choses
j'observe que le député actuel lorsque
claude lise a présenté son amendement
permettant d'avoir une autorité de
transport unique et bien il a sabordé
les efforts de claude lise
j'observe que lorsqu'il a fallu se
battre contre l'épandage aérien des
pesticides
il s'est opposé à un amendement qui
demandait et la fin de l'épandage aérien
j'observe aussi qu'il a systématiquement
soutenu toutes les politiques toutes les
politiques décidées par monsieur
hollande et que cela n'a pas conduit à
des résultats tout à fait honnête
voilà pour le ton de cette campagne pour
les législatives en leur appel au mois
de juin prochain de juin prochain
votre action en tant que conseiller
exécutif franciscain rôle l'actualité du
jour c'est cette situation centre
d'action médico sociale précoce du
lamentin local est salubre à l'ex
hôpital du bourg de la commune un
personnel en souffrance dans une
structure qui accueille en ambulatoire
des enfants jusqu'à 6 ans ayant tous
types de handicaps 350 familles sont
concernées trois cent cinquante familles
qui ne sont au courant de l'évolution de
la situation et par exemple cette
structure est amené à être fermés sur
décision du préfet c'est une situation
dramatique
je dirais même tragique c'est une
structure qui dépend du chum qui ne
dépend pas de la partie financièrement
mais c'est une affaire qui nous était ce
au plus haut point parce que ça concerne
des familles des enfants en difficulté
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
rapidement visité les locaux et sont
actuellement qui sont des locaux qui ne
peuvent pas accueillir du personnel et
encore moins des enfants en situation de
souffrance ça c'est une chose qui est
claire comme on peut et on arrive à un
tel niveau de délabrement de structures
une vraie question d'autant que le
personnel
diverses reprises à alerter sur
l'évolution qui a été un coup de dé
gaulle de distillation des conditions
des considérations financières c'est un
manque de considération de la part d
encadrement de ces structures qui
n'arrive pas à comprendre francis carole
que en arrive à ça non c'est je vous dis
que c'est une situation dramatique et
pourtant il a pu y avoir de notification
lorsque j'arrive aux affaires et en
janvier 2007 à 2010 année bien peu après
j'entends parler cette grève j'ai ruiné
le personnel susan est sur place et
visiter et nous avons proposé une
mission de bons offices pour essayer de
régler la situation nous avons fait une
première réunion
nous sommes en train d'explorer des
pistes mais c'est une honte pour la mort
dès qu'on en soit arrivé à ce stade je
le dis très clairement et fermement et
la décision de fermeture du préfet est
là elle est tout à fait légitime
elle arrive peut-être qu'au plus tard
mais elle est tout à fait légitime et je
crois que il n'ya pas à chercher de
solutions de deux mille solutions il
faut qu'il vient pour le comme une
véritable alternative et que c'est que
cette seule pièce qui peut être fait l'a
tout de suite ce qui peut être fait tout
ce que nous sommes en train d'explorer
des voies avec plusieurs solutions
alternatives
nous avons des unions aujourd'hui même
avec les distributeurs et nantes est à
dire la rs et le directeur du chu mais
le personnel pour voir ce que nous
pouvons et obtenir comme solution mais
nous voulons faire en sorte qu'il y ait
une solution parce qu'on ne peut pas
rester non plus des semaines sans
recevoir ses enfants en est en
difficulté ses enfants mais en même
temps la grève est parfaitement légitime
parce qu'il est absolument insupportable
que des familles et des enfants soient
reçus dans ces conditions dans quelques
jours francis carole ce sera le 14
novembre ce sera la semaine européenne
des personnes âgées vous vous plancher
sur un schéma d'action territoriale de
ces personnes âgées des personnes en
situation de handicap
on en est où dans ce plan pour qu'on
puisse voir des choses sortir de terre
dans notre martinique
d'abord il faut préciser l'enjeu nous
avons aujourd'hui 20% de la population
qui a plus de 60 ans en 2030 et bien ce
sera beaucoup plus doux à peu près 55
mille personnes qui ont plus de 60 ans
et les plus de 75 ans ce sera aux
ou de saint quentin mais c'est ça c'est
considérable nous avons aujourd'hui à
peu près 6 5% de la population qui est
en situation de handicap d'après les
chiffres de l'homme des personnes ou les
gens quand même des tâches reçoit mais
des recherches de laisser nous permettre
de voir qu'il ya plus de 17 % de
personnes qui sont réellement en
situation de handicap voilà la situation
et face au vieillissement de la
population
face à ces situations de handicap il
nous faut mettre en place un schéma de
l'automobile le cema d'autonomie
consignes quoi concerne l'accessibilité
l'accessibilité à tous aux bâtiments à
la culture aux doigts etc
cela nous demande aussi de réfléchir sur
la prise en charge de ces personnes
comment les prendre en charge les ehpad
n'hésite pas à domicile et le métier à
domicile il ya toute une série de pistes
peut être qu'il faut pas gâcher
l'ensemble de ces de ses possibilités
il ya aussi la question de la silver
economy même si je dois décliner comment
comme on la décline en noir parce qu'on
aurait surtout des personnes qui sont en
difficulté parce que vous avez participé
à ce grand rendez-vous du décideur c'est
avec la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de la martinique
le 22 septembre dernier à madiana autour
de cette silver economy française carole
et là on entendu manuel beaudoin
président sortant de cette cci dire
qu'on ne peut pas se faire du fric sur
cette silver economy
on ne peut pas dégager des bénéfices il
faut une vraie politique avec un grand p
est-ce que ce plan d'action territorial
serait ce là avec ce schéma de la grappe
et surtout ce fondement l'article schéma
de l'autonomie des personnes âgées des
personnes en situation de handicap a
justement pour ambition d'explorer et à
partir de là de dégager des politiques
publiques sur tout ce qui concerne les
personnes âgées y compris sur l'aspect
du développement est connu de la silver
economy
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
j'ai souhaité que tout ce qui concerne
l'économie sociale et solidaire soit non
pas dans ce qu'on appelle l'économie dur
mais soit dans l'économie sociale
aujourd'hui nous avons créé une
direction cette économie sociale et
solidaire qui se sont un peu écarté un
quand même de toutes les décisions alors
que c'est elle qui fait tourner les
choses s'étaient alors c'est pourquoi
nous voulons redonner sa place à
l'économie sociale et solidaire je
voulais simplement d'une part corde
dans la nouvelle organisation que nous
avons fait de nos services il y a une
direction pour la première fois une
direction de l'économie sociale et
solidaire de l'insertion
ça c'est une première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que le président régional a
décidé de lancer très rapidement la
conférence la conférence de l'économie
sociale et solidaire parce qu aura lieu
dans quelques jours comment elle aura
lieu un peu plus tard en début d'année
voilà parce que seulement
seulement là le secteur de la des
personnes âgées permet de maintenir plus
de 10000 emplois seulement ce secteur
des personnes âgées
c'est dire l'intérêt de ce secteur du
point de vue économique mais
fondamentalement nous voulons aussi que
kylie a une éthique dans
l'accompagnement de ces personnes contre
la maltraitance pour le bien-être de ces
personnes pour le respect et ça ce n'est
pas gagné
c'est vraiment une bataille essentielle
à mener parce que nous on population est
vieillissante et parce que tout
simplement la question du respect de
l'être humain est une question pour nous
essentiel convaincre également cette
jeune génération celle qui va faire des
études ou bien celle qu'il veut contrat
martinique qui lie à tout ce champ
d'activités possibles mais qu'on ne
viendra pas forcément beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent il faut le
dire aussi ça alors il ya les gens qui
sont dans ce secteur tout dépend d'eux
des responsabilités qu'ils occupent tout
dépend aussi de leur niveau de formation
ce qui est bien c'est que c'est un
secteur qui ouvre des possibilités
il faut que nos jeunes aussi s'y
intéresse d'ailleurs nous avons commencé
notamment lors de la semaine des
personnes avaient comme avons tenu
récemment nous avons évité plus de 800
collégiens un grande réunion pour
pouvoir pour susciter des vocations
voilà pour susciter des vocations et en
même temps les sensibiliser parce que
toute la question de la com on perçoit
la personne de personnes âgées comment
perçoit la personne en situation de
handicap sans souci c'est une question
sur cette question de culture
ce qu'il n'y a pas de lâcher des années
est fort si son nom n'apparaissait pas
la première dame vous savez pas ce matin
qu'on découvre que l'amendé sera un
département avec le plus de seniors nous
le savons nous savons très bien d'où la
volonté et de prise normale est jeune et
de notre collectivité d'accélérer à la
fois les réflexes et la prise de 10 leur
timing est noté l'insee que nous on a
voté en
en juillet au plus précisément je vais
octobre octobre novembre 2017
nous aurons voté un nouveau schéma ce
qu'on appelle schéma de l'autonomie des
personnes âgées et des personnes en
situation de handicap il reste à 10
secondes et ce plan concernant la petite
enfance la jeunesse et la famille nous
avons lancé en 10 secondes c'est parce
que nous avons considéré qu'il est
essentiel d'apporter des réponses à la
petite enfance à la jeunesse et à la
famille donc nous avons lancé en même
temps le schéma de la petite enfance de
la jeunesse et de la famille on y
reviendra merci francis lavoie rite avec
nom rappelle que vous êtes conseil
exécutif en charge des affaires sociales